wir treffen uns jetzt gleich hier in der
sonnenallee mit deborah feldmann die uns
ein bisschen was über das theaterstück
erzählt dieses theaterstück hat sie
nämlich hier wo sie als allererstes in
berlin gewohnt hat entdeckt ein die burg
ist normalerweise eine seele die die
welt hätte verlassen sollen
und es irgendwie geschafft hat bei
diesem ausgangs prozess widerstand zu
leisten
[Musik]
da er nicht mehr in seinem körper heften
kann braucht er um in dieser welt zu
bleiben einen anderen träger league dran
und kann an liegt leer
sie sind einander versprochen was schert
man kennt das wort im deutschen
bescherung aber lehrers vater wie sie
mit einem anderen verheiraten grant
stirbt an seinem gebrochenen herzen nach
seinem tod fährt sein geist in lehárs
körper gabriel wie ihr den dieburg
austreiben
dieburg ich biete dir zu sagen wer du
bist
niveauvolle rabbi ihr wisst doch selber
recht bin
und vor allem will ich meinen namen
nicht sagen
ich frage nicht nach deinem namen ich
frage wer du bist
ich bin einer von denen die neue wege
suchen neue wege sucht derjenige der den
geraden weg verloren hat geradewegs zu
eng
warum bist du das mädchen gefahren ich
bin ihr marschierte ich bin nicht tot
du hast unsere welt verlassen und du
darfst nicht er zurückkehren bis das
wetterhorn des messias ablenkt darum
befehle ich dir den körper des mädchens
zu verlassen damit nicht ein lebendiger
zweig des ewigen volkes israel lobby ich
weiß wie stark und möchte ich ihr seid
ich weiß dass sie engeln und serafin
befehlen könnte aber beim ihr werdet ihr
nichts erreichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier bin ich dann drei 2006 ist die
autorin debra feldmann aus einer
ultraorthodoxen jüdischen community in
brooklyn geflohen
einige jahre später fand sie dann hier
in neukölln ihr neues zuhause
debra erzählt mir dass sie so gut wie
niemanden kannte abends ausgehen weil
keine option sie hatte ihrem kleinen
sohn zu hause
stattdessen lud sie einfach wildfremde
leute in ihre wohnung ein und die leute
saßen darum und satz nach vorn haben
geraucht nahm quatsch und zwar immer was
dabei was wir dann gehört haben wir
geschaut haben oder diskutiert haben
manchmal jemand würdigte vorgelesen zwar
immer irgendwas kulturelles was ich hab
das nicht bestellt aber es ist so
geworden weil ich war ja von künstlern
und kreativen so umgeben dass es
selbstverständlich war mir eine
russische judaistik studentin brachte
ihr eine verfilmung des die burg aus dem
jahr 1937 mit
[Musik]
es ist leas hochzeit ihr vater will sie
vorteilhaft verheiraten doch sie ist
bereits hand versprochen die seele ihres
verstorbenen geliebten hat von ihr
besitz ergriffen
hier führt sie einen tanz mit den toten
[Musik]
der autor des stücks saalmann am ski war
auch ethnographie wollte das jüdische
leben in den osteuropäischen städten
zeigen eine welt die wenige jahrzehnte
später durch die schoah völlig
vernichtet wurde
die uraufführung seines stücks erlebte
an ski nicht mehr mit zum ersten mal
nach seinem tod aufgeführt wurde
ich glaube das waren ein ziemlich großer
erfolg auch und es ist dann immer wieder
vor allem osteuropa und dann in israel
aufgeführt worden
dann gab es eine lange pause zweiter
weltkrieg und ich glaube nach dem krieg
gab es immer wieder hier und da eine
aufführung aber ich würde sagen
heutzutage ich glaube es ist bekannt es
ist ein titel den man erkennen würde in
gewissen kreisen aber ich glaube es gibt
keine große begeisterung mehr für dieses
stück und das finde ich sehr schade
es ist im grabe ihm nicht gelungen leer
den geist von cannes auszutreiben
die seelen der beiden wollen einfach
nicht loslassen
der verein sich freiwillig mit ihrem
dieburg
wie soll es da hier so schwer ich höre
wohl deine stimme nur sehe ich dich
nicht getrennt bin ich von dir durch
bahn und gericht
wie süß ist deine stimme wie das war in
meiner vielen still stiller nacht wer
bist du werde ich hierher gebracht
ich habe es vergessen
in deinen gedanken nur habe ich gedacht
ich hab vergessen nur durch deine
gedanken wenig gedenken sich ich
erinnere mich in stiller nacht habe ich
süße tränen vergossen und im traum deine
hohe gestalt genossen
mein herz ist zu einem licht hellen
stern gezogen was du es der mir das
leben aus der brust gezogen
warum mein herz bist du von mir gegangen
ich konnte deine seele nicht erlangen
haben alle zäune und kreise müssen
besiegen bin selbst noch über den tod
gestiegen hat alle gesetze und zeigten
verkehrt hat mächtige starke gewalten
zerstört und als der letzte funke mir
entsprungen bin ich aus deinem leib zu
deine seele gedrungen
der erste grund warum dieses stück so
auf mich radikal bewirkt hat damals ist
ist das ende
weil alle andere dieburg geschichten die
ich kannte enden immer damit dass der
rabbiner schafft den druck raus zu
treiben und dann bleibt das mädchen
geheilt wenn etwas geschwächt zurück und
alle sind glücklich und hier sagt das
mädchen
auch gar nicht die austreibung ich
kümmere mich selber um die sache und es
ist für die zeit ziemlich cool
ja das ist das war für mich irgendwie
sehr befriedigend eine geschichte aus
1914 zu lesen die zu so einem ende kommt
wenn man das in meiner gemeinde in den
neunziger jahren ist nicht geschafft
hätte so eine geschichte zu gestalten
[Applaus]
da fällt man hat über ihre
lebensgeschichte ein buch geschrieben
unorthodox die gleichnamige netflix
serie ist inzwischen weltbekannten mit
einem emmy prämiert hier sieht man die
arrangierte hochzeit nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg begann ultraorthodoxe wie die
familie von debra fällt man sich
besonders streng an die regeln zu halten
sie cups hätten sich völlig ab diese
entwicklung lässt sich nur als reaktion
auf den holocaust verstehen streng
religiöse wie dies hat maracas idem
sehen die shoah als strafe gottes für
mangelnde frömmigkeit
inzwischen gibt es immer mehr aussteiger
debra feldmann lebt heute ein säkulares
leben in berlin
und doch spielt die jüdische kultur für
sie immer noch eine wichtige rolle
das theaterstück der de bug bedeutet der
autoren viel
es trägt den beititel zwischen zwei
welten eine beschreibung die auch auf
ihr eigenes leben zutrifft in diesem
fall bei der geschichte von salamon an
ski könnte man argumentieren dass layer
sogar von anfang an bewusst raum für
ihren die botschaft dass sie eigentlich
die aktive figur ist in diese geschichte
und dass sie diese liebesgeschichte
selbst steuert das fand ich sehr reizen
aber ein depot ist quasi und das ist
mein heutiges modernes verständnis davon
in dieburg ist eine seele die sich dem
schicksal nicht fügt die sich gott nicht
macht der liebe will das softphone
berlin
jemand der sich nicht fügt der einen
anderen weg geht als den vorbestimmten
wie detlef feldmann ist auch der
schauspieler jeff filmisch aus einer
ultraorthodoxen community ausgestiegen
in unorthodox spielte eine hauptrolle
und würde mit seiner eigenen
vergangenheit konfrontiert
für die serie sprach er zum ersten mal
wieder jede schon schlüpfte in die rolle
eines ultra orthodoxen chef vilbel schon
debra feldmann wünschen sich dass der
druck wieder auf den großen bühnen
gespielt wird denn das stück öffnet den
blick für die vielfalt jüdischer kultur
obwohl es bereits 100 jahre alt ist
immer als altmodische tradition
wahrgenommen hat war schon in der zeit
wo man wo man sich gar keine hoffnung
gemacht hat dass modernität eigentlich
total aufgeklärt und das dass diese an
die tradition so gewarnt sein wie es in
meiner gemeinde so war es ist eine
entscheidung
ja sie ist eine quasi beliebige
entscheidung und nur eine möglichkeit
von vielen wie man seine tradition
ausleben will wie man sie interpretieren
will
[Musik]
[Applaus]